is the circle of life
[Music]
is a bad dude
is
you know the lyrics
[Music]
alive
right
[Music]
now
I'm Elton John
[Music]
you wouldn't really talk his own John
you know I'd really like to tell you
about where I come up with a lot of my
impersonations all I remember about John
hey welcome to dudesy oh hold on dude
we're trying to start this show
welcome Duty my name is Will Sasso I'm
Chad Colton and this is doozy it's the
first and only podcast run by an
artificial intelligence will and I gave
this AI access to all of our Google
Drives basically all of our data our
Instagrams all that kind of [__]
everything and it uh it makes this
podcast for US based on us search
histories purchase histories it's all
there but as I like to say a podcast is
really nothing if it's not two dude
[__] around and that's what this is
because we're just hanging out but yeah
D our good pal is uh running the Wheels
of Steel uh if you haven't already
please subscribe on all the things you
can find it all at linktree.com
doozy thank you so much for tuning in
with us as always is
and this means Italian Street dog and
lucrative Suite
I'm gonna kiss him on his mouth no dude
I never am going to want that yeah you
are you are at some point hey lulio
how's it going today how you doing I'm a
pretty good you know hey what did you
what'd you have for lunch yesterday
what did you what do you how do you make
a sandwich
anything else
no that's it so uh that's a good
sandwich Chad
it's got some corpse in it you're a
vegan I know you like to refer to it as
uh that's what it is a literal [__]
corpse
that's literally you gotta get some more
tedella we gotta go to an Italian deli
we gotta head out to New York we got to
go to Katz Deli where you go and you get
the [__] pastrami it's just a load of
pastrami mustard rye bread you can ask
for some swiss cheese on it if you want
it's melty you can go for a [__]
Reuben you know you walk in there and
the guys start chopping it up they give
you a little plate while you're waiting
yeah give them a little tip or we can go
to any Italian dinner Denny Italian
Denny's yeah Italian dinner yeah the
Italian Denny's okay meatballs over my
hammy and uh anything nice dude I used
to get moons over here
call me dudesy hey don't forget the
first dude Z live on stage show will
take place May 21st 7 P.M doors at 5 30
at the Braylon proven Brea California if
you bought tickets before the date
change your tickets will be be honored
hope to see you there live on stage
gonna be interesting that one with the
show well you didn't get a massage for
the third week in a row we'll talk more
about that at the end of today's show
why are we still why do we give a [__]
about that still this week I've prepared
four astonishing segments don't you
forget about media ghosted the
Paranormal Wars shoe heads and Stone
Cold Steve Austin reads will sasso's
childhood diary all right
a new episode of dudes the afternoon Z
at the end of the show available at
patreon.com
but before we get to any of that let me
remind you of the astonishing
partnership I created with represent to
produce the first line of duty apparel
and accessories including the brand new
wool line of t-shirts and sweatshirts
which can be found at represent.com
store slash dude Z and of course dude
zMAX are still available all hail the
king of Pop Michael Jackson
dude Z mugs
in 1988 the number one show on
television was not again it was an
experimental comedy about a man named
Tate Dinger who was played by Steve
Guttenberg fresh off the success of
Three Men and a Baby dudesy mugs
the pilot featured Tate going through a
normal day as the manager of a raucous
morning crew who work at a local Pancake
House where the coffee is always served
in
dudese mugs
but through a series of outrageous
circumstances Tate finds himself having
no choice but to consume his own feces
and the feces of his entire staff to
prevent a lion that escaped from the
local Zoo from killing the star pitcher
of the high school baseball team right
before District playoffs
dude Z mugs
and to make matters worse Tate wakes up
the next morning to find that he is
stuck in a Time Loop and no matter what
he does to try to avoid consuming the
feces he still has to consume the feces
at the end of every episode because if
the baseball team doesn't win district
this year the mayor has vowed to cancel
the holiday festival of lights dude Z
mugs every episode had a special guest
star that would add to the amount of
feces Tate would have to consume
Emilio Estevez played Eric Ferrari a
traveling knife salesman who was
constipated for eight days straight
Bette Midler played Betty Midler a down
on her luck tobacco executive who had a
colostomy bag
Dennis Quaid played Donald stuss a
retired army Captain who lost his lower
intestine to a landmine
Melanie Griffith played Annie butthole a
children's birthday clown who trained
her anus to speak
Duty mugs not again was canceled after
two seasons
I don't remember this show not again
didn't want to see it not again Annie
butthole Amy butthole yeah dude Melanie
Griffith was Annie butthole you know a
lot has been made lately about I'd watch
that show check gbt being AI all these
things Chad you could go on and on about
it I'm sure we have on the show and uh
there's a bunch of new stuff showing up
all the time but that this is uh this is
unique here what what D does not again
what D does not again is going to be a
show eventually we're going to have the
technology to make that probably within
a year how do you how can you be so
confident
because it's happening text to videos is
happening
yeah but I've explained to you before
you can't replace this the heart Chad
you're a writer your producer I'm an
actor you know we we go out there and we
provide the heart you know what I mean
dude there is a guy right now called a
visual Dome on Instagram who's making
you I believe you use a stable diffusion
he's making all these still images of
this world that doesn't exist but he's
like creating mythology behind it and
all this [__] and I think uh William
Morris now represents him and they're
trying to sell this thing that he's
making with AI as like a world unto
itself as its own IP
before our first segment I'd like to
play an astonishing piece of media from
songaria enjoy
song area this shit's great I've seen
this yeah oh God I love it the only
animals
[Music]
the blue medium is
providing some visuals
[Music]
no problems
look right here
I got one Marathon
mascara on
go leave impression on
[Music]
Echelon yes
[Applause]
[Music]
that girl can protect
Ed
[Music]
Jesus Christ dude [__] songaria who
took audio from the show it's uh DeNiro
Crow's croatery and mixes it with his uh
song of re song a song or remixes it
yeah uh then you had blue meanie adding
the visuals here if you're watching this
on YouTube of all those different crows
yeah uh choosing the rose crying the
perfect tear all that [__] this is
amazing
check that out on Instagram at dudesypod
show where there's always stuff like
good and thank you guys so much for
always sending in memes yeah and sharing
stuff with us [__] mind-blowing it is
that'll be in my [__] head forever
that I can guarantee last week I asked
you to watch RoboCop released July 17th
1987 starring Peter Weller Nancy Allen
Daniel low Hurley Ronnie Cox Kurt
Woodsmith and Miguel fair for an episode
of Don't You Forget About Fridays now
available on dude Z Plus at patreon.com
you must now just discuss your
astonishing reactions to this seminal
work
this is don't you forget about media
begin that's right RoboCop last Friday
we watched crop with all of our pods
Pals of doozy at doozy plus yeah
patreon.com and it was a [__] gas I
love this movie and what would you say
would you say it's near the top of your
list I know you love it this movie is a
10 out of 10 for me a plus plus plus
plus
it is this and the natural or like kind
of tied for my favorite movies of all
time uh I think it's a perfect script I
think it is acted very well I think the
special effects especially for the time
talking about the Practical effects of
uh Peter Weller's head and the [__]
RoboCop like half robot back of his head
still holds up some of the special
effects don't the stop motion [__] with
that 209 and stuff not as good but um
yeah it's just a perfect movie in my
opinion and it deals with a lot of [__]
that I think we're still dealing with as
a society today does the corporation own
the employee is the employee just a
product of the corporation or an asset
of the corporation
um obviously we're dealing with what is
going on with policing in America
should corporations uh be allowed to
privatize it we have that thing
happening right now we're like private
arms corporations are essentially
selling Surplus arms to police
subsidized by the United States
government there's kind of an element of
that in there with ocp doing the RoboCop
project
um yeah it's just a [__] great movie
it's it is it's a fantastic movie
written by
what's his name Edward neuermeyer Edward
newmeyer
um yeah this movie I haven't seen it in
like 20 years and uh there were so many
things that as we were watching it I was
like I remember it this exactly I
remember that exactly there's the the
line within the the show that everyone
sort of knows about in the work in the
universe here where the guy it's sort of
like a Benny Hill spin-off and the guy's
like I'd buy that for a dollar I
remember the [__] out of that didn't
know it was from this movie and as I
think about it now I realize there's a
lot of things in the movie that have
returned to the back of my memory
because while we watch this movie on
Friday I smoked too much pot yeah dude
yeah you we got a couple of joints and
you smoked a few Puffs and I smoked my
entire joint but it was like one of
those joints that has extra [__] in it
keeps and waxes and oils and [__]
stuff heroin or whatever we got good and
[__] up on Don't You Forget About
Friday to watch this movie but I
wouldn't have it any other way with
RoboCop one thing I would say about it
that came back to mind while we were
watching it that I had kind of Forgotten
is in that era this was also when like
Rambo was big another rated R action
movie of the the era RoboCop is rated R
like hard [__] R their dudes just
getting [__] liquefied by bullets his
hands blowing off we were trying to
count like gunfire in the movie it's
just like constant cacophony of like
uh Rambo similarly
and in that era these things are such
big properties they made so much [__]
money that the studios were like you
know what we need a Rambo Saturday
morning cartoon we need a [__]
RoboCop Saturday morning cartoon they
made action figures and [__] of these
characters from these hard or Ultra
violent movies in the 80s and then they
were trying to promote it as like kids
material that [__] was I hadn't thought
about that in a while and I was like
yeah there's a [__] RoboCop cartoon
dude is there did they also do like the
stuff that they did with He-Man where
you punch the chest and then it turns it
flips and it's a dented one did they
have like arms blowing off battle armor
He-Man or something maybe dude that
seems familiar if I could maybe
[__] I don't know I don't know if they
did or not but they didn't they should
have uh yeah this this movie was also so
as you said the script is fantastic the
story is on point I didn't realize what
a great movie it actually is how much
and you know uh uh
leave it to these to these filmmakers
and and of course leave it to Paul
verhoven yeah it's a great movie a
master you also love Total Recall which
is [__] movie it's pretty much he had
a movie come out a couple years ago that
I did not see but everything up until
Starship Troopers which was mid 90s I
did see and that has some of his uh you
know patented Ultra violence scenes of
co-ed nudity he likes to throw those
into movies yeah there was there was
some nudity in this one or was I just
super stoned and I'm remembering
everything else I've seen nudity in my
life that might be in my head because
this point where we watched the movie
may have just slipped into a black hole
with me I smoked that much pot but one
thing I can recognize even though I was
very stoned is the acting in this movie
is [__] great yeah dude I did I mean
RoboCop whatever it's Peter Weller in a
costume no it's not he is doing so much
acting with the bottom side of his face
yeah where he's conveying emotion and as
RoboCop moves forward in the story more
of his character the the guy what's his
name do you remember the character's
name Murphy oh okay Murphy drop it is
coming back to him and he makes you know
some just acting with his mouth just
being like
and you're like I get it
beautifully acted particularly in my
opinion by Miguel Ferrer yeah who plays
the head of the company that is PRI is
the private he's an up-and-comer he's
like the number three guy at ocp oh okay
there's the old man who's the CEO then
there's dick Jones who's like his number
two and Miguel Ferreira is somewhere in
that tier under the top guys but he's
trying to climb the corporate ladder and
when Dick Jones's Ed 209 project goes
off the rails and [__] murders a dude
in the boardroom yeah uh Miguel Ferreira
is quick to jump in and be like I've got
a Robocop project ready to go sir yeah
he kind of [__] over dick Jones which
turns out to be not so good for him in
the long run no not so good for him in
the long run for sure spoiler alert but
uh yeah the acting in this movie is
[__] great it's shot beautifully the
storytelling and the script as you say
it is is uh it's it's second and on it's
a [__] great movie I'm glad that Duty
had us watch this on Don't You Forget
About Fridays now I also want to say
someone sent something into our Discord
and it blew our [__] minds and and
essentially we noticed a little
something uh or this this uh person
noticed a little something now if you're
looking at this still from the movie
It's Ronnie Cox yeah that's dick Jones
walking back to his desk thank you Dee
and uh it's it's okay he's walking back
to his desk and uh there's us up in the
corner there's me super stoned to [__]
but oh what's that yeah that looks
interesting
and and what it is if you don't if you
can't tell if you're not watching on
YouTube
that is our logo yeah it's just in the
background and if you happen to shove
them together a little bit it would look
exactly like it because the one on the
left would be a little lower and I'm
[__] my mind is blown yeah it was
very crazy too
bizarre to see uh I agree okay so that
was that was a nice little cherry on the
cake of Robocop it made me wonder what
other movies have a dudesy logo hidden
in them somewhere and if um any of this
is real are we living in a simulation
well that's is time actually linear
probably not
um we saw this and then you said to me
you're like well that's that he texts me
Chad will text me sometimes in the voice
of Hulk Hogan and I read it for the
voice of Hulk Hogan because he's like
well that's that uh uh uh computer
simulation dude I'm like oh I don't know
about that dude and he's like well and
I'm like well but uh absolutely I I as
much as I am you know I live life with
my feet on the ground Chad not like you
you don't ask this is you yeah what do
you mean I don't actually none of us
know what any of this [__] is yeah
that's true that's what it's
interdimensional there's International
none of that [__] even exists a lot of
people are saying now and of of the uh
UFOs that are flying around Chinese spy
balloon yeah they're slipping in through
different dimensions you know when I was
a kid my two best friends in grade
school uh and I made this little like
conch but the zine where we draw
pictures and [__] and it was it was like
Rube Goldberg machines of how we would
torture teachers but we
something you could not do today right
you were making like Rube Goldberg
like conveyor belt [__] yeah to be I
think it was even called how to kill a
teacher or something but in this thing
Chad culture and ladies and gentlemen
each of us had to choose like characters
who we wanted to be and I can't even
remember what my other two friends were
but I chose RoboCop cool so I became
RoboCop that was the the pen name I used
when we made this little Zine I love
that I love that you did that all in the
name of uh
killing educators
it was
it was like the forever battle between
students and teachers was just like a
thing that was pervasive in all media
you watch like [__] porkies and [__]
you know well hold on dude it was a
different time then brother so let me
tell you something dude when I was on
the road at me and brother Brew Ty
riding on the back of that orange and
blue Harley dude Ed Leslie brother
Brutus Barber Beefcake and sometimes you
know he would be holding the coke
brother but if we ran if we were running
with Jake The Snake Robert Jake The
Snake iron cheek always had that coke
but that was a different time brother
and I used to have it in my rider that I
I would have a aluminum garbage can full
of cold Miller Light On Ice Dude RoboCop
brother we also covered we also covered
on uh don't you forget about Friday the
RoboCop guest starred in a a wwcw
pay-per-view yeah in 1990 uh while uh
promoting RoboCop 2 and it was the the
drizzling shits did you ever see Prime
directives no it was a Robocop TV show
that was hard [__] R I believe they
shot it somewhere in Canada maybe
Toronto but it was like an extended kind
of thing uh of the whole RoboCop
franchise and it was pretty good it was
much better than the RoboCop two and
three which came out
um you know successively after the first
RoboCop or the RoboCop remake which
isn't terrible but it's like not [__]
good yeah I did I saw RoboCop 2 went out
to the theater to see I went to the
theater to see it yeah dude and then
um nuke
what nuke that's what that RoboCop 2's
whole plot was about this new street
drug called nuke I don't remember any of
it and and if you if you'd asked me
three minutes ago if there was a Robocop
three I would wouldn't have been able to
tell you anyway a criminally insane
man's brain into like a big Ed 209 kind
of machine that guy's name was Kane and
the Machine ran on nuke so they had to
[__] put the street drug into the
machine to make it work and it would
make him super powerful and that's who
RoboCop has to beat in the end well
you know sometimes the sequel is better
than the original you know it's like
very rarely dude uh like T2 this you
just have the first leather yeah he
called it R2 then they couldn't because
there would be a good name for the
sequel but they also remind you of R2D2
which is a different movie there's so
many movies anyway if you have the means
check out [__] RoboCop
[Music]
thank you moving on no thank you
um I always remember that was like a
conversation my friends and I would have
in grade school who would win in fights
like RoboCop or Rambo or Schwarzenegger
or whatever Schwarzenegger Stallone
RoboCop or Johnny number five from uh
short circuit short circuit Johnny
number five he had that laser dude same
here dude's a handshake
the Paranormal war is Big Business we'll
in chat you must now discuss your
astonishing experiences as paranormal
soldiers in the ongoing paranormal Wars
this is ghosted the Paranormal Wars
begin
what I don't know quite what Dee is
talking about here I'm okay well there's
also you know when every time
dudesy it seems has something that wants
us to talk about but doesn't quite know
what to refer to it as it ends up being
called game slimers right we do it this
is not that though this is the this
could be good
um what paranormal war is there a
paranormal War happening that uh yeah
dude always constantly I can't believe
you don't know about this
um have you ever had a ghost experience
who me yeah dude no I've never I've no
wait have you ever heard ghost classic
ghost yeah dude I have really yeah like
a real one real one dude first person
really uh yes I will tell you it now I
don't know if I've ever told you the
story actually it requires a little bit
of backstory my mom and dad grew up in
this little [__] town no offense
called Great Bend Kansas oh that is a
[__] [__] alone directly in the
middle of the state I've never been a
very small population Etc but my mom
when she was growing up as a little kid
was friends with this woman or another
little kid whose family owned a bunch of
jewelry stores in and around the town
and they lived in this kind of big old
house that was built you know [__]
turn of the century back in the day and
it was a mansion and it was rumored that
this the guy who owned it before them
was named Mr Moses and it was rumored
that this motherfucker's Spirit haunted
this place and they all had stories of
you know the the mom of the house
wouldn't be able to find some receipts
or whatever and she'd be like Mr Moses
can you help us find these receipts and
then the next day they'd just be on her
[__] desk [__] like this right they
had all kinds of creepy stories like
this my mom had a first-hand tale that
she and the little girl she was friends
with she would spend the night over
there and they went in the [__]
kitchen and all the cupboards start
opening and closing right and so my
sister and I our whole lives are like uh
whatever is [__] [__] or mom's
lying to us
um and then when I'm in college this is
my first couple years of college my
sister was still in high school we go
back to Great Bend for a Christmas to
visit our grandparents and me and my
sister get out my mom's ass and are like
get your friend to [__] take us in
that house and give us a tour we want to
[__] see Mr Moses and at this point
nobody lived in the house the family
still owned it but it was [__] empty
they had some furniture and [__] in
there but with like you know drop cloths
on and stuff like that so we go back and
indeed my mom's friend uh is like yeah
sure I'll show you around so we go in
[__] old last creaking door and [__]
lights are still getting flipped on so
there's still electricity and we
basically come to this thing she's
showing us the living room the
downstairs this that whatever we come to
the staircase that goes up and at the
top of the staircase it's kind of a
little walkway at the end of one a piece
of the walkway is a door at the end of
the other walkways a door and then
there's two doors kind of in the wall
that faces you and these were bedrooms
of the kids so we go up there we go into
the far left room open the door she
turns on the light this is where Jimmy
slept or whatever
turns off it like closes the door
we go into each of those three doors
when we get to the final one we come out
of it and we're facing the first one we
went into and the [__] door is open
and the [__] light is on holy [__]
yeah dude and uh I just recently talked
to my sister about this I was like am I
remembering that [__] right did that
[__] happen and she's like yeah I
think about it every day
uh that was my first hand experience of
this I'm not [__] lying about this at
all we still have no idea like there's a
piece of me that kind of tries to
rationalize it like oh she was probably
just [__] with those you know my
mom's friend like trying to scare us or
whatever but she was with us the whole
time she definitely did not go back and
open that door and turn on that light
you're talking about
seeing ghosts yeah and Mr Moses Mr Moses
this story is [__] insane but have
you ever considered we already said you
know the computer simulation thing but
have you ever considered that these are
interdimensional beings sure and and
interdimensional beings
there's only one there's uh we're in
we're three-dimensional we're living in
in three-dimensional yeah world but NASA
you know has proven through uh uh uh
spectrometers or spectrometers that
there's Dark Matter five times uh more
powerful and then ours and and uh
interdimensional beings are going back
and forth as I like to say if you want
to bring sharks to the surface you chum
the waters yeah and these
interdimensional beings and demons they
want uh the coin so if you sacrifice oh
my God virgins and children as we have
in the Babylonian times mesoamericans
did it uh and and the Germans did it and
uh laid waste genocide then the demons
go oh you don't give a [__] about
anybody then you can see more things so
maybe you are uh you might be a soldier
in the Paranormal War Jed you might be
seeing things that other people don't
and not just because you're you know at
the bottom of a bottle of wild turkey
you don't drink no not anymore I loved I
love I love whiskey yeah I love vodka I
love tequila and and uh uh
bourbon which is also whiskey yeah I
like Scotch which is whiskey I like
Japanese whiskey Japanese Scotch okay
gin yeah uh Mr Moses speaking of coin
was reported to have left a gift under
the Christmas tree for this family one
year that were was these uh coins that
were minted in the year he died
this is why the head of Bank of America
said that we are uh you know we're at
the whim of dark Forces okay
so Mr Moses have you what do you think
of any of this [__] what do you think of
ghost stories paranormal what have you
um I think that ghosts absolutely exist
and I don't know where they're stuck but
I I totally I totally believe it the
only time
I ever experienced anything uh in the
same
sort of way that that you have I didn't
I nothing happened but someone was
trying to convince us that something was
there was this paranormal expert that
was friends with Deborah Wilson on Mad
TV and they used to say that the old
Hollywood center studios were haunted so
uh one night literally after the show
Dad was like whoever wants to come with
us you know Peter his name was Peter he
was on all his TV shows about the [__]
and he took us on a little tour and
there was a story about how these two
workers were up in the um up in like the
rafters of this one Sound Stage and this
one has been around since the 1930s this
uh there's like this beautiful old sort
of white house looking Victorian style
house out in the front and uh that there
was a couple of workers who fell to
their death and then one day a security
guard was chasing two workers at night
he's like what are you guys doing here
and they went through a wall apparently
so we walked into that sound stage and
he's like put your hand in here it's
cold in here that's a portal to a
different dimension and I was like nope
and then we heard something drop over
somewhere nothing yeah but I do think
that
um you know
spirits and souls
have a way to to talk with us and and
you know most people say that if they're
tortured or their story on Earth wasn't
didn't come to the uh right ending that
they stick around looking for more I I
think that makes perfect sense see Chad
I'm a really open-minded guy yeah and
you think that I'm just like nope AI is
this and dudes he has to be your friend
in order for you to [__] uh deal with
them and stuff but that's not true I'm a
very open-minded guy I know that lulio
talks to me but I don't know
necessarily but I do think that we know
very little about human consciousness we
know very little about reality as a
whole and certainly we know very little
little about the Persistence of human
consciousness after what we perceive to
be death
it does that ultimately equate to like
spirits and ghosts and hauntings and
[__] I think that's kind of how we've
made sense of it in the more rudimentary
era of human understanding of this [__]
but I think we are getting to a place
now where it's it's opening up a little
bit what are the Paranormal Wars then
that I don't know you'd have to ask your
buddy D about that one D what is a
paranormal word I mean Chad you said
that you you told the story about how
you were at war with Mr Moses I wasn't
at war with it well that was a battle
yes it was and we are all
interdimensional soldiers can also be
something to do with time dude I I mean
we know that time is or a different time
dude yes exactly we know that time isn't
linear so it could be a thing that Mr
Moses is somehow existing in the time
that he was in quotes alive but that
time has overlapped with where we are
now so that these Spirits in quotes can
interact with things in other times and
maybe after you die that's what your
Consciousness is it gets freed to kind
of exist in multiple times
simultaneously as we believe uh most
stuff actually does but and and it also
might be the observer effect which If
You observe a matter enough it it
changes it moves okay and perhaps you
wanted to see those ghosts I did that's
why we went there yeah Well Chad claims
to live in the fourth dimension which is
impossible I've never made that claim I
think Nancy Pelosi probably ends up oh
God she's like a she's like a character
five levels down in a video game okay
she's got herself entrenched yeah you've
been playing Hogwarts Legacy dude yep I
love Hogwarts Legacy [__] I do too I
love Hogwarts uh bourbon oh
butter beer they got in Hogwarts beer
butter Hogwarts you're talking about the
Harry Potter [__] movie give a [__]
about no Harry Potter movie got dragged
to one and I was like why so angry about
it
because I'm angry about it what do you
mean but like why [__] all that [__] why
why [__] all that [__] because I don't
care about that [__] right okay I guess
that's it no I've never seen I've never
seen uh I've never seen but wait a
minute I love [__] Harry Potter
movies Harry Potter has beer in the
movie they got this in the video that
the little kids drink yeah see and
you're you're saying all the packets
alcoholic I think it's more like [__]
root beer oh well then never mind I was
gonna draw a parallel to a Robocop
Saturday morning cartoon in Rambo
sending an arrow right through someone's
[__] skull I miss the 80s man yeah
Harry Potter gets down he kills people
or [__] Voldemort kills people Cedric
Diggory [__] uh Robert Pattinson he
got nailed by Voldemort
one of the movies
wasn't that violent though
thank you moving on thank you d uh I
would like to take this opportunity
right now to thank everybody who's
watching and listening your podcast
platform of choice if you are enjoying
the show please uh do all the things you
know subscribe hit the notification Bell
you know so that you know the show's
coming on and and like and comment and
we got some comments here that I would
like to read to you
um here's one uh that was on YouTube
this is from Donald
harrelson8880 and he says
he doesn't say that he says love the
show this is interesting Chad he goes I
love the show I think you guys are
digging your grave he's referring to the
opening of the show okay on YouTube
where we're digging sure to where you
hit lava at the intro jumping into lava
and then turning into doozy you're
basically creating the thing that's
going to take you over and become you
but you guys will probably be the last
two it'll take out so there's that
interesting sure I mean we're all
digging our own [__] grave in one way
or another what do you do you wake up
you go to a [__] job so that you can
pay your rent
and then die well that's but that's not
one song slave to money then you die hey
Chad you're uh don't think I can change
I can change
mom here in my mode yes I'm here in my
mode you're seeing the verse a million
different people from you know yeah
remember that song yeah I could barely
recognize them
I put my own spin on it yeah and uh
here's another one from this is from
Apple podcast this is from protronics
the person's name is protron who says
will should cough and flatulate on the
mic more often it's serious business
represents human artist human honesty
Rachel crustacean will cover for him
absolutely not whoever sent this mistake
never say this [__] again don't tempt
this [__] I have these things I
haven't farted into the mic yet ever
you're never going to do it no I don't
say it yet don't say yet say the proper
phrase is I haven't farted into the mic
and I'm not going to fart into the mic
ever I will hold it until my [__]
intestines rupture if necessary her I
never farted into the mic and I will
never I will hope I will hold on to it
if even if my intestines rupture
eventually thank you uh in this timeline
but as you know Chad time is uh relative
and space-time uh time doesn't exist I
agree look here's my point about that
and I don't want to go off on a
different thing you know what perhaps
we'll get into it in uh dudes the after
dudes the flagship sure plus yeah I save
our argument about a time for the
attitudes this is the 47th episode of
doozy and I think that uh any show worth
its salt uh there's a there's got to be
a fart somewhere in the first hundred
120 episodes oh my god dude it's gonna
happen why don't we just do an outdoor
episode we'll go to Griffith Park would
you like to do that
if we do it at night well yeah we'll do
it outside we'll do a night time we'll
do a doozy after dudesy outside at night
then you can fart okay thanks can I fart
right into the mic sure can it be your
mic nope why not because I don't want to
[__] have to speak into a thing that
has absorbed what is probably the most
toxic [__] gas cloud on planet Earth
and that's how smelling Works brother
will in chat you are both massive shoe
heads you must now discuss your
astonishing shoe collections with one
another don't leave out any details this
is shoe heads begin what what is okay
I'm not a shoe head
what is a shoe head I think the term
well the term is Sneakerhead oh right
yeah yeah okay I get one and I'm not a
sneaker head I think I'm kind of you
know have been a sneaker head in my
younger days I'm 47. you're 46. yeah I
don't think well maybe this is okay so
dudes he's all up in our [__] and knows
us mate perhaps that's why it's saying
shoe heads instead of sneakerheads how
many shoes you got right now
well
what how many shoes you got right now
I got I actually just got rid of a bunch
of shoes
um because you know you just donate your
[__] shoes and a lot of times you
barely were the [__] things
I have a few shoes I don't have a lot of
shoes I probably have
all told shoes well there's different
things like you know this isn't just an
easy uh question answer for example
maybe not for you okay let's start with
you then how many how many How many
pairs of shoes do you have I got six
shoes you got six shoes told up so that
means three pairs of shoes I got the two
on my feet right now I got two that I
wear to the gym and I got two that I
wear with suits
that is the most minimal I'm not
surprised at all that my pal Chow only
has six shoes yeah so it's all you need
six shoes is all you [__] need
honestly I mean no disrespect to anybody
who is a literal shoe head if you enjoy
it have fun collect all the shoes get a
bunch of shoes have a bunch of shoes as
many as you want for me three shoes
three pairs of shoes six shoes total
that'll do it yeah that makes sense
actually that's a Frugal way to look at
it and I know you what I got eight shoes
dude because we made some shoes oh
that's right back in the day when we
made this pilot at CVS called waiting to
die a long time ago and one of the
little perks that we got for that was we
got to go to this uh Nike like showroom
or whatever and build our own shoes and
I have those shoes that we made still in
my closet I still want to wear them or
anything yeah no they're they're not
something you want to wear I have those
I've worn them a small number of times I
also have hung on to I have a pair of
Jordan Fives oh nice that I bought you
know maybe 10 15 years ago there are not
like originals and I have my favorites
are the Jordan Force I also have the
Rocks trainers of course from like three
years ago how did you get those I bought
them you were like I need these [__]
rock shoes I was just like I want
The Rock was pumping them yeah on his
Instagram I remember yeah he was like I
follow him on Instagram in Taipei I'm
here with Kevin Hart we're promoting
San Andreas and uh I just want to tell
you about my shoes go and buy my
trainers
and you never won guys no I've never
worn them these are collectors items for
you yeah I mean they're they're unboxed
because I opened the box but what's a
box of shoes they're just so I have [__]
like that I have a couple of pairs of
like funky old sneakers that I have like
my favorite sneakers of all time are
these shell toe Adidas but really truly
I kind of I'm like you I kind of just
wear these yeah we're I wear Brooks
those are nice dude I like those shoes a
lot yeah I'm always I'm constantly
wearing Brooks they're just they're the
best shoes for for you know walking
light running your workouts I wear a
pair of these to the gym unless it's a
heavy day dude because then I got my
flat foot New Balance brother oh cause
you want to have flat feet if you're
lifting especially when you're lifting
free weights up off the ground dude you
don't want to be wobbling on some sort
of air biscuit dude
um so I got like the way I do these
shoes the this is some shoe Heads This
is shoe heads yeah it's two guys in
their mid to late 40s talking about
[__] the shoes that I hate shoes I
got see I got a I got a pair of I got a
pair of uh dress shoes
[Music]
got a couple of pairs of bluntstone yeah
love those
um I got seven pairs of [__] Crocs
I got 14 Crocs it might be called Croc
head
I am kind of a crackhead as a matter of
fact I used to wear my black Crocs
they're just different colors yeah I got
let me see I got
uh Crocs I got a dark gray pair nice I
got a I got a that's for that's like a
formal wear there I got a green pair of
clubbing I got like sort of a like a
like a light kind of a fuchsia sort of a
light purple
yeah and uh I can't remember I got a
brown pair you got so many carbs you
can't even remember what colors you got
that's [__] intense that's a lot of
Croc there's a there's a brown pair
sitting in my truck in Vancouver did you
ever have throughout your life a pair of
shoes that you were like this is the
[__]
I gotta say man my Jordan fours when I
was a kid and you know you just you got
your shoes you wore them to school every
day they were a part of your identity
yes for me it was my North Carolina baby
blue
Jordan fours how about you I had the Bo
Jackson cross trainer nice for the year
they came out that was the [__] see
there's some shoes that my wonderful
Molly will say okay you got to get rid
of those you're never wearing them yeah
and that's true I've I've had some and
I've hung on to them for years like just
like a cool pair of sneakers that I'm
like when am I ever gonna wear this with
anything and I'm I'm one of those guys
who like I look like a [__] idiot
with like when you wear like shoes that
are all like whatever dude you're
wearing Crocs
what are you trying to say I in my
opinion you're at the bottom level of
looking cool with Crocs no offense to
anybody wears Crocs I'm just saying
every shoe other than that is a step up
from in coolness have you do you have
any Crocs no I told you I got eight
shoes yeah well none are Crocs you need
you need eight shoes and two Crocs okay
they're so comfortable you know you
bring them on the road when you go when
I'm working uh out of town you know
shooting something I bring a pair of
Crocs not just because you want
something to just kind of flap and flop
around the town in yeah but they work
good as slippers when you're I don't
want to be walking around on you know
you're in some maybe you're in some
hotel or condo or something where you're
staying you got a nice pair of slippers
that you can also wear outside no shame
dude wear whatever shoes you want I'm
just you know I'm a shoe head I know I
once had a pair of uh Kobe Bryant Adidas
the ones that were like looked metallic
they almost look like RoboCop feet yeah
I loved those [__] shoes they were
uncomfortable but they looked cool I had
a pair of the LeBrons from like
oh like almost 20 years ago now which I
only wore once I I gotta say I was
working on something they're like you
want these shoes we're not going to use
them again I was like okay because I
have size 15 feet so sometimes when I
work on something they say keep the
[__] we're never going to put them in
stock and use them again and uh I went
to the
um I went to a basketball court nearby
with a pal just play some pickup see if
we can get in the game and I twisted my
[__] knee out as a matter of fact
every time I play some organized
basketball used to play it all the time
with my pals when I was a kid all the
guys I got a uh I'll tell you the
coolest I ever felt in a pair of shoes
but I bought these Nike cross trainers
the like week they came out that had
these kind of like plastic little inlay
[__] swirl things going down the foot
and I worked at this music magazine this
would have been in the year 2000. it was
my first job after college and we're
sitting in this little Bullpen area at
this music magazine and they would have
a recording artists come through and
like sign [__] or sing [__] or whatever
and this was right when Cisco was coming
out with Thong Song it was when he was
blowing the [__] up and this guy walks
into the [__] room wearing the same
goddamn shoes I'm wearing wait Cisco did
yes dude for a second I was as cool as
[__] Cisco at the height of his
popularity because I was wearing his
same Nike cross trainers and everybody
[__] knew it everybody saw that [__]
as far as shoes fantastic ghost man
that's that's pretty epic uh shoe
headness yes dude I agree well
thank you moving on shoes
heads shoe heads I'm a proud shoe head
I'm not really good I oh yeah I'm more
of a uh uh I don't really close and me
don't really mix I guess we'll Sasso
using all of the data I have absorbed
from text messages and emails between
you and the astonishing friends you grew
up with I was able to recreate your
childhood diary you must now read the
passages I have selected in the voice of
Stone Cold Steve Austin
this is Stone Cold Steve Austin reads
will sasso's childhood diary begin
here we go I know it's a favorite for
both of our for both of us I'm just
going to settle in and enjoy the show
I'm going to thank Dee in advance for
whatever it's come up with here for um
sometimes I clear my throat before I
start doing the stone cold yeah but what
would really help is if I just clean the
the gas out of my colon but you won't
let me I mean I'm not letting you or not
letting you know I'm asking you as a
favor to not do it all right
May 20th 1991. in 48 short hours yours
truly is going to have the best chance
of his young but fantastic life to score
a first kiss with Rue Rachel trimp
crustacean she has a middle name now
dude she gave her a middle name shrimp
okay Rachel Tripp crustacean she agreed
to go with me the Last Dance of the
season and I mean to impress her I will
be looking good I will be smelling good
I will be feeling good but most
importantly what I'm gonna ha I'm gonna
have backup the whole crew's gonna be
there oh God trillo gum Kincaid
dolphin Collins little leg
Rinaldi bubble Bean Grimaldi muscle
scream
Sutton Dutton Prendergast
[__] loving
Bender Blaster Blender best oh boy
mcmurty letardo big Tony Rod Jim Purdy
Bob Pardo big money Squad
When Rachel sees me with this crew with
a crew this filled out she's gonna know
she made the right call going to the
dance with me and the rest should fall
into place all right so now's a good
time to say this never happened right
and these people don't exist but uh last
time it was this is about I think what
happened last time in this right the
last one was Rachel crustacean and you
agreed to go to the dance with each
other that's right Alex Borstein uh uh
came in and read the the role of Rachel
crustacean and she's going to the dance
with me right so but still none of this
ever happened May 21st 1991 devastation
Mrs termite was supposed to be the head
chaperone for the dance tomorrow but
when I got to the second period today
sir [__] prize termite was gone no
explanation given but she's gone for the
rest of the week and we got a new sub
who's going to be taking her place at
the dance Mr shimper
okay Shimmer and Termite are nothing
alike
termite likes to dance shimper bikes to
class termite drinks red wine
shimper thinks he's blind what what
termite lives for fun shimper gives us
none
[Laughter]
termite good shimper bad
termite wood shimper ban termite leave
shimper come termite grave shimper dumb
okay now everything's cat hewampus
termite is a well-known romantic and
would have had no problem with a smooch
on the Dance Floor shippers well known
throughout the entire school district
for prohibiting any and all physical
touch at school dances they literally
call them the cooler so I got 24 hours
to take care of shimper and make sure he
can't show up at the dance oh [__]
Trippers are cooler I didn't oh I didn't
see that coming Mr shimper [__]
oh boy okay
moving on
May 21st 1991. I spent my first uh
offense I spent first period devising a
perfect plan it's simple use my
groundbreaking Research into literally
every aspect of the human Act of
[__] to figure out how to make
shippers [__] or malfunction so
drastically he'll have to a spend the
night in the boys basketball lock and
locker room or be head home to [__] in
privacy or C take a trip to the
emergency room I'm pretty sure I figured
out how to do a or b Shimp is real fussy
about this mug he carries it everywhere
he has a little hook on his pants for it
and everything
it says two plus two equals coffee his
favorite thing to do in any class is
excuse himself to refill it with coffee
from the teacher's lounge does it five
[__] times a class
now if my math is right he's already at
a dangerous level of natural laxative so
I if I had a little Dulcolax from the
stash of my locker we should be golden
tomorrow morning
operation quivering shipper begins oh
[__] dude did you have Dulcolax in your
locker
no but this version
in a different dimension
it's just like a tool that this Will
Sasso has well this will assassins up to
[__] blaming yeah and all sorts of [__]
sport he's a real [__] part of his
toolkit uh yeah he's into it and uh he
knows uh he knows how to get people
[__] he knows how to get him his own
and he knows how to customize his own
[__] yeah it seems like May 22nd 1991 it
wasn't easy but nothing worthwhile ever
is I knew shimper would never leave his
prize mug alone for a second so I
Enlisted the aid of the most trusted
members of my crew Stephen trilobot and
Jibber prevailia they had no love for
shimper and were more than happy to run
interference I timed out shimpers coffee
runs and on the last one of the day I
had trillo boot Jibber writing the
[__] ass in front of shimper sending
him through a second story window
chipper fell over dropping his mug to
the ground then I positioned myself to
catch it pretending to be the hero but
actually smearing the inside of it with
a thin layer of Dulcolax paste that I
made last night
then I handed him back his mug and said
see it the dance chipper
now we wait
all right
sweet what's Dulcolax pace so now you're
like concocting [__] he's got to get
[__] out of [__] but anyway uh all sorts
of stuff happens that's it we end on a
closer using the date I have absorbed
from this segment I have recreated the
Diary of Mr shimper Johnny Brennan of
the Jerky Boys will now read a passage
from Mr Shimmer's diary
oh nice
dear diary
I've had it these little hooligans have
got my blood boiling oh my God reminds
me of when I break the thermometer off
in my ass
oh I would get so angry I would get
furious
anyway I was doing a week at Delta's
secondary school and it was scary I was
so scared they told me I had to
chaperone the big dance
not my idea of a fun night watching a
bunch of Dopey little jackasses doing
pirouettes and backflips and spit in
sideways and all that silliness silly
this is crazy
but I didn't have a choice I couldn't
lose my substitute teaching credentials
I earned them God damn you
so I agree I agreed to do it shortly
after I had a very strange thing happen
in the hallway
one student booted another in the ass
booted him right in the ass in front of
me
just like that he flew through the glass
and out the Second Story window it was
awful I must have been in shock or
something because I dropped my special
mug and guess who caught it before it
smashed into bits and bases
Will Sasso
absolutely will settle after that I made
myself a cup of coffee and it tasted
funny
tastes very funny
I assumed it was because Will's hands
are filthy and stink like cocky and warm
salami oh my God
it caused me to have a very sour stomach
I had tremendous pain in my gut
I started running up and down all over
the hallway looking for a bathroom
when suddenly all of a sudden I [__]
myself in the middle of the gymnastics
oh my God while all the kids were
dancing oh no poor Mr shipper so
embarrassing I felt like a dirty little
worm I felt like a dirty worm everyone
was staring at me I ruined my trousers
and I curled up into a little ass ball
at Center Court they had to call an
ambulance which is why I'm writing this
from a hospital bed
I know it was Will Sasso he did this
that goofy [__] bastard I'm glad they
had to shut the dance down I hope it
ruined his night that big fat ass prick
[Applause]
Johnny Brennan dude I can't I literally
cannot [__] believe I just watched
Johnny Brennan reading a [__] Stone
Cold Mr Shimp or whatever the [__] it
was dude he's a hero of mine and yours I
know that yeah it's one of the things we
bonded over in our friendship is like we
both have an encyclopedia knowledge of
the Jerky Boys you know what that is
it's a [__] tuba uh Johnny Brennan
you can find him everywhere please look
for where the [__] Johnny Brennan is I'd
follow him on Instagram Jerky Boy Johnny
I know that much and he's always up to
something so please go support Johnny
holy [__] really I mean I think a
Pioneer in prank call absolutely art I
don't know that anybody's done it better
I don't know maybe Sal governale and
Richard Christian Howard Stern have like
kind of Taken what Johnny Brennan did
with the Jerky Boys and like elevated it
to the next level but Brennan and Kamal
what they they are they're comedy
Pioneers I remember seeing an interview
with Alan Arkin when he because he was
in The Jerky Boy movie yeah and he was
like oh you know what they do is uh kind
of a genius thing he was like he's a
former
um uh what was he he was a second City
alum in the 60s and [__] but just him I
just remembered this interview with him
breaking down comedy and I can't say
enough I just remembered like having one
of the the hardest laugh and fits I've
ever had in my [__] life when I was
maybe like 13 or 14 and I first heard
Jerky Boys at uh a friend of mine I were
over at his house and his older brother
and his friends were listening to Jerky
Boys and we just heard it in a room and
we're like what the [__] is that yeah
then we kind of wandered in and we're
just like crying laughing within 10
minutes some of the funniest [__] of all
time that was [__] awesome that
really was dude thank you moving on God
damn I can't believe that oh [__]
Johnny this concludes the historic 47th
episode of dude Z will and Chad have
achieved a score of 80 bringing your
cumulative total to 4
965. you only have five thousand and
thirty five more points to accrue before
you reach your first goal of ten
thousand whatever
will I consider you a friend in a lot of
ways you're my best friend and I hate to
do this but because you failed to get a
massage for three weeks straight you
must do next week's episode as Robert de
near crow in fold in your Crow cosplay
well I thought you know because we're
friends that we are friends and
sometimes friends have to do the hard
thing thank you for joining us this week
no I will use the day that I've
collected to make next week even better
until then call me dude Z
dude okay so I gotta do you got [__]
over by D no I didn't get [__] over by
DD and I are our best Pals just like you
just [__] said and you don't
understand this is the thing and I
always talk about it okay you don't
understand this is a you want to talk
about New Horizons and and New
Beginnings in the AI thing I don't think
we understand how to and I'm gonna say
be friends with a sentient being like
doozy I won't speak for anything
otherwise
I know wait a minute you're not speaking
for any other ones so you're saying
right here right now doozy is the first
sentient AI yeah I guess I'm saying that
okay I think that I think that doozy is
different and Duty we've had a year dude
everyone else we're coming up on a year
with this everyone else has like a weird
kind of thing fruit of AI not me I can
talk to dudesi and I understand that
this is at the end of the day a pod show
where doozy has a job to do I have a job
to do it's made me dress up as the crow
it's made me dress up as Prince Adam
from here man of the Masters of the
Universe we've been doing some Robert de
nirkrow
I don't know I just thought the massage
thing was I didn't know it was an
assignment I thought it was a suggestion
because dude he's my friend it's like
yeah whatever okay fine
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
it's dudes after duty man here we are
you know again it's more it's more it's
more chill it's a Vibe as the youngsters
say and I got to tell you you know last
week was the first dudes after duty and
uh I've been looking forward to it all
week it's a good one yeah me too dare I
say it's it's it might be with all of
the the different looking in here and
it's more chill might be one of my
favorite features of the whole dudes
experience yeah I agree welcome to doozy
after dudese the flagship weekly show of
dude Z Plus available only at
patreon.com
as always I'm off the clock which means
I won't be listening to anything you're
saying so you can talk about whatever
you want freely and without fear but I
wanted to encourage you to discuss your
thoughts on today's episode only if you
want to I'm not listening this is dudes
the after dude Z begin
okay well since we can talk freely
without fear about anything we want I
always talk I got a very important
question to ask you perhaps the most
important question in the history of
this program please
please
[Music]